[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: You can
go this job alone.
You can go the
leading route alone,
or you can do it together.
It's always more fun
to do it together.
We can get together and support
each other in great ways
because we're authentic,
we belong together,
and we're on a journey
to be strong women.
Be really open to change.
Be resilient, be tough.
Breathe deeply.
Some things are out of your
control, and that's OK.
Growth and comfort
do not coexist.
Invest in yourself.
Have mentors always.
Be visible, be present.
Be humble.
Humility is the
opposite of arrogance.
You take one thing and
say yes and figure it out.
If you never say yes,
you will never grow.
You will never push yourself.
Be a contributing
member of the tribe.
So be there for each other.
Like, once you find your
tribe, really be there.
Collaborate, collaborate,
and then collaborate
more-- more minds, more energy,
more enthusiasm, more support.
Many women live like
it's dress rehearsal.
Ladies, the curtain
is up, and you're on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]